all right what's the next category
actually laziest dream oh
[ __ ] this only has the one outfit in
their water so the laziest trip
to explain because it probably doesn't
make a whole lot of sense is the person
i think who wore the same amount of
shirts for the longest time right
yeah oh god something like that but
let's look i mean let's let's see
let's see i remember oh
wow we all okay so there's me connor and
god but
wait didn't chris get nominated in this
originally
i remember when we got like the original
nominations yeah from like the survey
chris was on there for some reason we
had to remove him
wait did he wear the same shirt twice i
don't know no no no i was going to say
it
i'm really sad i don't know where my
trash taste t-shirt is i've lost it
really lost it i don't know where it is
i mean i personally have worn this
jujita shirt many times on the podcast
i've
worn that nerve shirt many times um i
thought it was okay to wear the trash
tape shirt multiple times yeah it would
wrap it you know
what the [ __ ] real winner of this is
the [ __ ]
um jojo shirt that we got from uh
the amount of times like collectively
between the three of us we've worn the
glam jojo shirts
every episode is secretly so good we're
not sponsored by glam by the way we just
love that shirt exactly
um oh yeah fyi chris was on
the pole christmas chris was on the pole
okay
wait wait for the for the votes yeah why
was he removed
because he's only been in two episodes
how many votes
chris was on the original poll all right
um i mean there's not much to say
um i feel like it might be i feel like
it's you yeah
like it is you i think it's me always
insulted by my t-shirt
i feel like i've seen your emea shirt
about 10 times i like that shirt
it's a nice shirt i mean it's it's like
i i i can remember when you wear
something different because if it's not
the emmy
shirt or one of like your drab kind of
like t-shirt colors
drab yes brown is a great
t-shirt so one of so one of the uh so
one of the in one of the netflix
specials
joey only bought like one outfit or you
didn't bring enough outfits or something
like that
and so he had to borrow connor's shirt
and of course it was just like a dark
red you could have immediately it was
like the color of drywall
it's like yeah joey walks in and i'm
just like joey this looks like the least
joey outfit i've ever seen
i would never wear this person i need
something to tone down my white
white white skin just wear black i do
but i
like i like how all the screen shots are
wearing black yeah
there was a guy on reddit who actually
did the calculations and went through
every single episode
he actually quantifiably figured out who
had the laziest dream oh okay
the trash takes one runway this took way
too long it's not even funny
crochet actually counted every single
shirt that reappeared
and was worn twice so do we have the
results of this yeah the results of this
on the next page oh
okay so let's have a look at the results
have the results so scientifically
speaking
connor had 29 unique outfits
so you wore the trash taste shirt four
times so you're repping the show
yeah yeah you're wrapping the shirt
repping the shirt best but i wore it two
episodes back to back as well okay i
think that was the two episodes we
promoted it
probably oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
think we all wore that episode but
uh this is the only page i have of the
trash
oh this is the only page uh i just
didn't include it
oh okay i mean it doesn't matter yeah it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter
if you want it yeah if you want to look
at the if you want to look at the full
thing then we'll leave the link to yeah
in the description i guess yeah shout
out to uh nope
389 on the reddit you didn't you did
god's work who is the winner
by voting by the way by the viewers
[Music]
[Laughter]
i have a feeling it's not connor oh it's
chris brown
you did it chris you did it chris you've
won an award
you won an award for the laziest
even though you've been on the show
twice what was the percentage
he won with fifty point eight fifty
point eight percent
fifty fifty percent
i want to see the other shirt he wore
like other than this one what was the
other shirt he wore the
navy blue color it was just yeah oh my
god
wait wait so oh wait who came uh second
uh
connor yeah yeah third was
with 9.7 wow oh that's
this is hilarious best moment so far
chris congratulations you've won
congratulations you won the lazy strip
award congratulations congratulations
chris congratulations
we'll give you a musical yeah i think i
think we were mocking chris that's why
we put it in we're like yeah
i think this is meant to be like a joke
nomination right yeah
yeah because the results are already
there right we already know quantifiably
whoever
we know who is scientifically proven to
have the laziest trip but we know who's
the winner
man's about the feeling yeah and we all
feel that chris is the laziest guy we
know
so just it's just like you know you know
obviously everyone got the same feeling
just emanates lazy drip energy exactly
obviously come on chris you to you've
got to up your dreams you've got to step
it up chris yeah